[Music]
reinvention is is really breaking
something down and completely revisiting
what it meant originally so traditional
advertising you'll see somebody running
a ad on Twitter or Instagram some kind
of paid media and that's how people and
brands tend to engage with their fans
right now we re envisioning that and
completely changing the way that brands
are able to engage with their fans by
letting them get a physical product
delivered to that fan within an hour you
know Gregg and myself
Gregg's my co-founder had no agency
experience no media experience and so
for us this was really jumping in
headfirst and and we learned a lot as we
went one of the big ones for us was kind
of getting our heads around this Silicon
Valley narrative we're a Midwest company
but you you constantly are fed this
Silicon Valley narrative of raise a
bunch of money hire a bunch of people
get a bunch of offices and you know
early in our history as a company we we
fell into that narrative and so that was
one of the the most difficult things was
learning how to navigate that figuring
out what is real life and what's
tangible and you know versus what we
hear from the media or what we heard
from other startups because every
founder is always killing it you never
really hear the the real detail about
what's going on behind the scenes and so
for us that was you know one of the big
the big learnings
I would urge somebody looking to get
into the space to really think about
what's going to help them create a
viable business at its core something
they can generate revenue something that
can work towards profitability one
specific piece of advice that we give to
a lot of people particularly consumer
products is you know before you go to
launch your product thinking about what
your headline would be what makes your
product and positioning so unique that
somebody would wanna write an article
about it that was something that we kind
of adopted you know early on and and I
think that can be helpful to people if
if you can't think of what that headline
is maybe it's a good idea to think about
the way that you're positioning it to
the market
[Music]
you